hi that reject nation
I'm Greg Alba and I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch Marvel Entertainment
TV spots for endgame we are filming this
Monday afternoon I think right when the
end game premiere is going on for all I
know there might have been more TV spots
or another one that dropped by the time
I'm uploading this but based off the
time we were uploading this John are
gonna be going to a press screening for
endgame in just a few hours our review
for the movie will be up Wednesday
morning 6 a.m. Pacific Standard Time I
really love it if you guys go check that
out because it's the final sketch that
Jon and I have put together while living
together after this we will no longer be
friends the channel is dead yeah that's
the worry everyone has there's a
thousand percent what's gonna happen we
just wanted to check out the final TV
spots that we could check out before we
go to this reading I haven't watched any
of them I just downloaded for them oh
yeah which are powerful found summer
begins in time and just drop them into
the iMovie on Mac exported it so it's
gonna play it is one long clip alright
one of these is factually negative what
summer begins
[Music]
[Music]
we turned 80 oh hey
sleek a man's mr. Antonelli found in
excess of spikes
[Music]
[Music]
yeah just like that
[Music]
[Music]
what was that commentary to make about
that last one it's funny watching all
these back-to-back because you're seeing
that they're taking lines from other
scenes like they showed that scene in
that TV spot but that wasn't a lot in
that TV you trust me we gotta finish
this
I missed that giddy optimism and not die
trying
would be nice they're just mixing it all
around there's only really one specific
section that is he flicking and man off
of his shoulder let me pass low that
down really yeah it is that man he's
like you know but is that a creative cut
into the neck I mean that doesn't look
like it's from the same scene no that's
a creative cut into the next one but
that's not the actual shot right there
yeah unless they're really pulling one
over on us it seems like they have very
much verified that Tony gets back to her
seems like that is a foregone conclusion
I love the moment with Black Widow
hitting the punching bag that reminds me
and bbs when Ben Affleck weight lifts
and hardcore before going to fight it
Duty infinitely strong that's gonna get
you warmed up you know you got a maxim
shoot that target yes those are all the
things that Everlast gets a good
sponsorship in here yeah well hey you
know it's gonna be that pistol that
brings down Thanos in the end the new
rock stars do a breakdown of any of
these because I want to see a whole
breakdown of this gin that they have
someone's deadlifting 45 pound weights
yeah it's a bar because I did the
barbell
is what I want to know i like tony is
like space shields uses that and Finiti
work yeah he's - glad it's back i keep
wondering when this moment is gonna cuz
they keep switching different lines
around tony he has a shades on he looks
like it's pulling up in his car and caps
all shaved looks like they're outside of
YouTube headquarters it looks like the
movie has just ended and they've
completed and they're setting up for the
next movie kids they're gonna have a
handful in the future and I did talk
about this on movie talk I know some
people kind of gave me a lot of crap
about this Oh what did you do with the
Rocket Raccoon telling everyone on the
ship who hasn't been to space you better
not throw up on my ship I pointed out
how in Captain Marvel I found it kind of
I found it funny how Maria Rambo and
Nick Fury fly into space see they don't
seem to really have much of a and
emotional reality there's a kind of
there can be a physical reaction either
too caught up into space this is
something that their bodies are just not
used to on an emotional and physical
level they're not used to it so I like
that Rockets actually pointing that out
for all these guys and someone came at
me in the comments exam like these guys
said training and shield with flying
ships so I'm like a how high do jets go
when they train B wasn't that like early
shield days were they going into space
and doing those things new Nick Fury you
know we need you down here to clear some
things up
yeah well that's line to I mean at least
one of those they were like we're gonna
die trying and I noticed that they put
that over Tony and cap which seemed like
kind of a ribby sort of like ah we're
kind of gonna go the audience with this
you know yeah them maybe what I'm really
looking forward to is watching ant-man
Tony and rocket interact with each other
because especially in these TV spots it
seems like the Rockets sarcasm has
really been elevating a lot of the
darkness here alright avenges time to
live up to your name
wait how I look forward to seeing dr.
Strange's Tony Stark interact that's
what I have here now in terms of the
humor you just want to see all the wise
asses get together and be wise asses
together absolutely with who's the
wisest ass of them all and then which
one of them vomits everywhere when they
go to space
I hope someone vomits that's actually
they've canards day Captain America
okay they have the three hour runtime
they're able to spend a lot more time on
things so there will be like a 10 minute
sequence where they have to stop because
everyone's just really sick
it'll be like Family Guy you know
they're just like their two--it asleep
vomiting because they want to get that
realism good of them it's good thanks
man getting funnier than you talk I have
a theory called blood force comedy just
keep going until it's funny yeah this
will be the last TV spots we watch going
to the screening I know it doesn't feel
real stress out about getting good seats
24 hours directly from this moment and
actually yeah show me yeah we're at the
stuff I want to give a page from the day
shout-out to a lovely lady named lenay
Lynnae is one of our top reward to your
patrons being whatever video she
requests we must do and put up on
YouTube she's introduced us to a lot of
wrestling I haven't heard from her in
about three weeks I messaged her saying
what request do you have you said you
were gonna take a little vacation from
the Internet take a little break from
work I don't know what that involves I
imagine a lot of hardcore alcoholism
because you kind of just strike me as
that sort of individual I hope you pick
up that this is not sarcastic in purely
sincere I feel bad when you have that
reward here and yet you're not asking
for a video for us to cover so instead I
have to give you this weird shout-out to
try to get your attention
Lynnae get back on the internet all
right you can't spend all your time in
the backyard with the bottle and an axe
chopping up bits of wood it's just for
people or people knowing how you can be
I just miss you and I want to hear back
from you and also don't decrease your
pledge it's okay if we don't do that you
know what we're supposed to do on our
end which is deliver that video yeah
whatever as long as as long as your
pledge stays that amount of work we're
okay we're happy with you I want this to
look like we're trying oh we're trying
so hard guys he can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
battle to keep a look out for our room
non-spoiler review